IRL will be live in Miami with Patrick
Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates and
Luke rowski join us there get your
tickets by clicking the link in the
description below or by going to
timcast.net
that are similar in essence to what
Scott Adams had said in the last
election that you know that that he
believes covich believes he'll be hunted
down and killed in 20 after 2024 if you
know if we lose he says if you're
conservative of the large platform have
you talked to your family about how
you're going to be framed for a crime he
quote tweeted this he says 2024 is life
or death and he quote tweeted saying
John Eastman facing disbarment for a
legal memo on an open constitutional law
issue Trump judge said maral Lago only
worth $18 million Michigan elderly
Republicans indicted Georgia fake RICO
case scotus is the only stop Gap once
that's gone there's no law I'm not even
convinced scotus is because when it came
to Texas V Pennsylvania in 20120 scotus
said we are too cowardly to answer a
question of original jur un original jur
addiction which is insane they have to
and they didn't I believe Thomas and Leo
are correct I highlight this to make the
point while cernovich and Scott Adams
saying it's life or death may have been
hyperbolic then maybe now cernovich says
it's not hyperbolic and these are all
goober conservatives who don't think so
he does point out something very
important in this tweet Michigan elderly
Republicans were indicted it is not
going to be Execute Order 66 as I stated
in the previous segment it is going to
be you are you committed fraud that's
right uh yeah we we uh we think you
committed fraud um so you're under
arrest elderly Republicans were were
tasked were were electors were asked to
sign documents in the event lawsuits
were W they would require these
documents it is a normal constitutional
procedure Michigan indicted them and
they are facing the rest of their lives
in prison overdoing what they are
constitutionally requested to do they'll
use the IRS oh hands down they Obama
already did it yeah Obama went after uh
what tea party groups part grp that's
right y so it's it's crazy to me that
people are like cernovich is out of his
mind okay again like I don't know about
you just being dead right away but 10
years ago Obama used the IRS to Target
his political opponents look where we
are now look where we are they're
they're arresting
lawyers y they're they're arresting
lawyers the judge a judge in New York on
summary judgment banged to gavlin said
the Trump organization is to be
dissolved and then sanctioned the
lawyers for arguing it's there's the
system already is is fractured and
busted up yeah we see it like we were
talking earlier about in 1992 with like
I don't know we talked about Rodney King
earlier in the week but like just the
chaos and the things that have happened
that didn't get televised but now like
anything any guy can tweet out eight
things that have happened Aaron
Danielson we talked about a million
times like that probably wouldn't even
have got National media attention or
maybe it would have but likely may not
have gotten National media so I agree
yeah this could be an example of just
taking these things and blowing them out
of proportion but I think the Trump
indictment are just beyond the pale like
that is it's history it is it is one of
the most egregious violations of of this
country's values laws Norms rules the
Constitution and it is one of the most
if not the most significant thing that
has happened to this country since it's
founding right you can talk about the
Civil War and then I would say Okay
perhaps we can have a conversation about
the Civil War that when Abraham Lincoln
was trying to he tried to I don't think
he did actually indict a sitting Supreme
Court justice but this was secession and
then conflict
so right now this could be on par with
these moves that led to 1865 it's like a
we're in a different country and
literally like same name but because
like someone in in Tacoma Washington
will be online talking to their best
friend in England and they're they don't
have any friends in Tacoma because
they're online so it's like a different
world a different reality this country
now 1861 I should have said you know
it's like we're a different country
that's the difference between this
country and other countries or has been
that we don't beat each other political
opposition uh in the jur Box we beat
them in The Ballot Box that's really you
know something that one of the only
things that really does or did separate
us that's not happening now that's the
real difference and the major uh shift
and you know
I people ask me H how is this going to
impact the election I think it's just a
matter of it's a fight of it's a fight
between Wills it's a matter of resolve
and you're going to get hit with
something new every day they want to
remove him from the ballot here and you
just brought up the Civil War the last
time Democrats removed a candidate from
The Ballad was Abraham Lincoln in 1860
that's it it's really the only time I
can even recall it being done They
removed him from the bout in southern
states theyve removed him from the B and
here's the funny thing what they're
trying or want to do now is remove Trump
from the ballot in blue states that he
would otherwise have very little prayer
in winning anyway that's what happened
to Lincoln and he still won but uh there
four candidates that time that's right
the vot the vote was split similarities
are sick
man really what if it's Cornell West
parallels RFK Biden Trump giving Trump
37 38% but enough to win yeah yeah and
then they they take his name off the
ballot Six States right this is crazy
because there could be and that's why
you saw it in Colorado in a situation
like 16 when we had disaffected voters
going to you know Gary Johnson Jill
Stein Colorado got close there Tim got
way closer than it should have been so
did New Mexico what people need to
understand is that St how generational
theory is not this profound Discovery
it's just the writers cycle for Earth
simulation seasons 1 2 3 and four right
season one the American Revolution
season 2 The Civil War season 3 World
War World dead War woo they had to spice
thing up spice things it wasn't just
enough for America to be fighting and so
now we're going for how about
interdimensional no Civil War and World
War III and then
aliens all at the same time every time
something crazy new happens that is like
a we pass this Rubicon we we cross this
line it does seem to be aliens something
that they're trying it but the water's
too hot they keep pulling their toe out
it's just people don't buy it but it
used to be and you were kind of maybe
you're alluding to this but I was
thinking about it what you're talking it
you'd get the presidential vote whether
you hated the guy or liked the guy you'd
vote it didn't really matter like yeah
your your Commander's the commander but
Congress runs the show doesn't really
matter so like let's all enjoy life as
Americans that's what we get to do
together you you I'm sure you know about
voter turnout in the early days of this
country right what the voter turnout
percentages were I mean I don't have
them off top of my head uh like they
were 10% yeah they were they were
abysmal until jaon and democracy which
started to ramp it up and then which
reached around like 20 20 some per which
makes sense because then when women's
suffrage happened it basically doubled
so women started voting what did Jackson
do that enticed voters one man one vote
you have no representation and then
there's actually a lot of parallels to
Trump as well and he loves Trump loves
Jackson um you know he won too early
like Trump which I think you could argue
Trump came in and I I I mean I I
remember in 16 saying to people you know
the election of one man a revolution
does not make here there still a bunch
of cheese Republicans in the in the
senate in the house they're you know
this is not going to go how a lot of
people think it's going to go that
happened in Jackson and uh the The
Establishment status quo came at him and
he had to regroup and and this is
something Donald Trump still hasn't I
don't at least not yet I have not seen
him learn he should just run with his
own slate of candidates look at what is
going on right now with this dead fight
with the the CR the continuing
resolution he wants them to defund the
laware political laer that's that's just
not going to happen with the the current
bunch of uh cowards I mean you know that
are in Congress it's not going to happen
we know who these people are we know the
talent that's in these same districts go
after them Trump should be running the
America first ticket not the Republican
ticket right you know not he should be
running the America first ticket and if
you're for me in Texas 12 you vote for
John OA if you're for me you vote for
Matt gates in Florida one if you're for
me that is uh that benefited a lot of
bad people in 2016 Trump always gave
more than he got from the traditional
GOP Coalition and he D he drug a bunch
of losers over the Finish Line who would
then stick a knife right in his back so
this is something he's got I know he's
you know the guy's busy with lawfare
he's trying to run for president it's
you're going to repeat 2016 and 17 all
over again if you don't do this so like
where Lindsey Graham he he said
everybody vote for Lindsey Graham and
then they did and he won and then big
mistake okay so he should you're saying
he should specifically like should he
should he denounce certain people that
he has no because you don't want to make
enemies yet like there's nothing you can
do about Lindsey Graham and plus you
want to win South Carolina you don't
want to lose um there is up country
super conservative South Carolina and
then there's ory county you know and
other places around Charleston you don't
want to lose that so you don't pick
fights with people you can't remove but
um there are you and there are their
allies and congressmen are up every two
years we know who the Senators are and
one I just mentioned Texas 12 this is a
woman who is the uh Appropriations
Committee so this is relevant to right
now I think Matt Gates was just on your
show making a deal about this K Granger
made a deal with Trump she had Chris
putam on her butt and putam was in the
lead and she said you know I need the
president's help for his endorsement he
said I need your help on impeachment she
he he gave her the endorsement she
defeated Chris putam when he needed her
support in the impeachment hearing and
and the vote she went home pretended she
was sick and refused to vote by proxy I
mean this is the kind of spineless and
it's not even spineless in that case
it's just backstabbing it's treachery
you know and you're not going to affect
meaningful change with that kind of
treachery if I told people that there
are maybe three to five tops and I think
I'm being generous at five
solid Republicans in the US Senate out
of all of them you mean I I wonder how
many would be surprised Matt Gates had
to fight tooth and nail to defeat that
spending bill for Ukraine finally it was
that was a big Turning Point 119
Republicans voted against it uh I think
hund and something voted for it but
against had more than not that's a big
deal because that doesn't happen the
house Republican conference is probably
85 to 90% coward I may even be being
generous with that they're not really
what they claim to be John dwarte out in
California 13 ran on border security I'm
super trumpy and by the way I need
migrant workers so I want to keep the
Border open he voted against the uh the
the trans Bill the other day I mean
these people say one thing completely do
another when they get in there and this
is a uniquely Republican problem you
will not see this on the Democratic side
when was the last time Tim you saw a
Democrat promise something
right that's a
liberal um you know I don't want to say
orth yeah liberal Orthodoxy and then get
to Congress and stabbed their voters in
the back AOC did it with what famously
with Israel well right away they all the
all the progressives were like whoa whoa
she's taking the establishment deadline
now and yeah I mean unlike you know and
that's that that's peripheral compared
to like trade or immigration is for
Republicans you know so you know
seriously you know um I just I just
don't think their words are worth
anything yeah they should Republic
they're not
put care if they're Democrats or
Republicans there's like seven
Republicans where I'm kind of like yeah
yeah maybe maybe like if they were like
I'll endorse you but then you'll vote
for me on that and they need to put it
in writing or they need to put it into a
smart contract so it triggers
automatically they don't get to to
resend their their agreement but would
that be
like Todd zi uh he's had great research
on this like the whole system relies on
that kind of a trust you know it is a
status quo I'll scratch your back you
scratch mine uh but when it's like
complete betrayal you know then the the
whole thing's just there's no benefit
for them to to sign something like a
smart contract that automatically
executes because the the possibility of
changing is what gives them leverage to
leverage one side against the other
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. and
become a member over at timcast.net